ccsd superintendent dr jarrah is giving
his executive team raises totaling more
than 400 thousand dollars this decision
is getting strong criticism for many
teachers support staff and
administrators kate houston live in
studio tonight kate those who you spoke
with are concerned about the timing of
this and the reasoning behind it
yes this comes less than a week after dr
jarrah was fired from his position by
the board of trustees and as the school
district deals with hundreds of
vacancies one educator tells me seeing
executives getting a raise of this
magnitude is a slap in the face it kind
of makes me feel like i'm not i'm not
worth anything to the school district
frustrations are growing as teachers
learn of a sharp salary increase for 15
executive positions compared to the 3
percent raise they received we venture
so much with ccsd it's almost like
another kick when we're already down in
a letter to the school board dr jarrah
says this will help them compete for and
retain talent the largest raise nearly
45 thousand dollars will go to the chief
financial officer i think it's shocking
and to think that the taxpaying public
has to support that is just
unconscionable stephen augsburger
executive director of the school
administrators union says raises of this
magnitude are usually tied to
performance results but that's not the
case for ccsd test scores
and student achievement it's in the tank
and we are mired in the bottom scores of
the country augsburger notes those
receiving raises also signed a letter to
the school board expressing their
support of dr jarrah ahead of his firing
and he's calling on school trustees to
take action then they need to give clear
direction to a superintendent who's been
terminated and has 30 days to exit they
cannot continue to allow him with
operational authority and
decision-making authority because what
he just did demonstrates that he cannot
be trusted
school board president linda cavazos
weighed in on twitter she says the memo
from jarrah was unexpected and further
review of these raises is possible
cavazos voted to fire jarrah last week
now i did reach out to the school
district many times to get some
questions answered and i have not yet
heard back